this is the video that you guys have
been waiting for the highest end i9 5600
m macbook compared to the new beast the
m1 max with 32 gigs of ram today we're
skipping all the comparisons we did that
yesterday you guys can check out that
video for all the differences we are
just going to focus on performance so we
have the same spec systems but this year
it's actually 600
cheaper for the highest and 16 inch as
far as performance compared to
just a week ago which costs
4100 we're going to test cpu and gpu
performance multiple photo editing
applications video editing with davinci
resolve xcode logic blender and much
more and on top of that we are
unplugging these machines both of them
are at 100
so we are gonna look at the battery life
with heavy use you guys can see how
excited i am let's start out with a very
simple one but something everybody wants
to know about geekbench 5. we have eight
high performance cores from the m1 max
along with eight from the intel core i9
both with our recommended 32 gigs of ram
let's go ahead and see the results as
these tests are running i have to tell
you about our giveaway we're giving away
a 2500 m1 pro macbook pro and all you
have to do is be subscribed and comment
below with these launch week videos at
the end of the week we're going to
choose one video and then one random
comment and i don't care if you are
somewhere outside of the united states
if i have to ship it to you pay import
fees whatever it is we are going to get
one of these beautiful machines in your
hands we also just got the razer blade
advanced with the rtx 3080 and the
latest i9 processor this beast has 16
gigabytes of video memory along with the
32 gigs of regular ram one terabyte ssd
and it costs 3 400 with that 4k oled
display so make sure you guys have those
notifications enabled so you guys don't
miss out on this comparison against the
m1 max the scores are in and we have 62
better single core performance and 76 on
the multi-core
really big improvements even against the
acor i9 now that single core that really
helps for simple tasks so i'm gonna go
ahead and open up speedometer 2.0 this
test web browsing performance and the m1
systems are insanely quick wow we have
271 we've never seen a score this high
the best was the m1 at 220 compared to
152 that's about 80
faster performance for web browsing and
of course other tasks now let's go ahead
and jump back to geekbench and now we're
going to switch over to the graphics as
you guys know this system has that 5600
m which is the best that you can get it
was a 800 upgrade compared to the 32
core m1 max let's see what we get for
our compute score all right guys the
scores are in and we have 42 800
compared to 69
478.
that is 62
faster but as we already know geekbench
is actually not using this gpu to its
full capacity so the score is actually
higher than this we are going to open up
gfx benchmetal this is optimized metal
performance for gaming i'm running the
off-screen test here because this new
macbook has a much higher this
resolution display almost 4k
and as we run this i want to do
something that's very interesting i'm
using this terminal command to see how
much wattage this m1 max uses let's hit
start there alright guys our scores are
in and this is a bigger difference than
i expected with the intel in the amd
5600m this was the first laptop that
we're like guys you can actually play
games with this graphics card it was
incredible and it got
129 frames per second compared to 309
for the m1 max that is 2.4 times better
performance so you guys see the
difference here whereas geekbench wasn't
that big of a difference and we're going
to continue on with real world graphics
tests in just a bit i also want to note
these fans you guys probably don't hear
it
but this thing after it's been done for
over a minute it's still trying to cool
down the fans are spinning where with
the m1 pro max lemon max should be
called the pro max right
with this one the fans were silent the
whole time now with that said let's look
at our wattage obviously this thing had
its fans blaring
and i'm shocked to see that it used
71.85 basically 72 watts of power
previously i never saw go above 55 so i
don't know if apple made it you know
have more powers more wattage i'm not
sure but this is crazy and nobody's
mentioned this before but the m1 max
uses 40 watts of power under full load
with 32 cores so the difference is
almost double basically over 80 percent
more power that's required for the 5600
m
even though for gaming loads at least
now that the max the m1 max here gets
2.4 times better frames per second so
that's a huge difference in performance
and power needed the next thing i want
to test is blackmagic raw speed test not
disk speed test this tests how well the
cpus and graphics can decode blackmagic
raw codex and look at this the intel cpu
actually decodes at 48 frames per second
compared to 29 so the m1 max is not
decoding as well but the graphics guys
25 frames per second for the 5600 m for
8k compared to
199 almost 200. we will do an actual
blackmagic raw test individual resolve
in just a bit the next thing that i want
to test are the ssds both of these are
one terabyte models we have almost 5 900
on the right and 5 300 read compared to
2 800 and 2700 that's pretty much double
the speed for read and over double for
right definitely a great improvement and
now let's go ahead and compare 3d
rendering performance with cinebench r23
as well as fans heat and noise all of
that stuff i'm going to start out our 10
minute stress test and we're going to
also see the frequencies and any thermal
throttling that we have bam right away
we got almost 89 watts for this eight
core i9 processor and almost instantly
the temperatures are over 90 degrees
celsius and we're cruising at 3.4
gigahertz our m1 max is running at 28
watts of cpu power compared to currently
65 for the i9 all right guys we have
about 30 seconds left and man there are
a lot of differences first let's take a
look at the thermal camera 43 degrees on
the m1 max you guys can see those hot
spots where the vents allow the air to
escape and we have
45 on our i9 16-inch macbook pro now
look at the fans right here
on the i-9 they're maxed out they have
been since a minute to the test whereas
with m1 max they are barely above idle
the machine is still silent after 10
minutes of running this test
now our i9 it actually is throttling to
55 watts from 68 where it started and
that's because it just got too hot and
we're thermal throttle down to what 3.0
2.99 gigahertz definitely way too much
heat with this system all right guys the
test is done
and man this is crazy even with the i9
the score is 8105
compared to 12 129 this thing is pretty
much as powerful or almost as powerful
as my insane 15 000 mac pro while using
less than 30 watts just under it
compared to 68 until this thing kept
throttling and throttling and throttling
so we have basically 50 percent better
performance with 2.2 times less power
usage and the fans were silent the whole
time compared to max speed even a couple
minutes after the fans are still maxed
out trying to cool this thing down the
m1 max chip and those the 10 cores there
they're absolutely insane and now let's
move on to xcode for all of you
programmers out there how does a new
system compare to the previous best
laptop thank you to max ermenko for
creating this benchmark and making this
terminal command for us that
automatically launches xcode and
compiles this code all right guys this
is an insane speed right here
first off the 8 core i9 took
197 seconds compared to
93 seconds with the m1 max chip
that is just an incredible score over
two times faster 2.12 times faster and
that is only three seconds behind the
best score ever for xcode which was a 28
core xeon in a mac pro i think that's
what like over 20 grand vadim yeah for
that system this is a laptop
that is absolutely insane xcode
performance for all of you programmers
this is a beast and now we are testing
out logic we've done some tests ahead of
time to save you guys time we don't make
want to make another 40 minute video
again and it looks like the i9 can
handle 98 tracks in logic with a new
logic benchmark without crashing
compared to
155 tracks
with our m1 max ship and if you're
somebody uses logic just go and get the
m1 pro you actually get no better
performance if you don't need the
graphics don't spend the extra money now
the other difference is the fans here
are pretty much a full blast right now
compared to idle literally we ran this
money many times the fans were
completely off now they barely spun up
on one side so for logic if you're doing
audio production you don't want that fan
noise right that's where this thing
really comes in and next we are gonna be
testing blender you guys asked for it
i'm gonna use two tests one cpu and one
gpu base so we have this party tug scene
downloaded you can download it and test
it for yourself from their website i'm
gonna go ahead and select render right
here and we're gonna do our gpu test wow
the m1 max just killed it 5.9
seconds under six seconds that is
incredible it was almost instant we're
still waiting here all right guys the
5600m
40 core graphics are finished and it
took
33 and a half
seconds that's 5.7 times longer now if
you guys remember in our metal test it
wasn't even twice the performance but
when we're using an optimized program
and blender is optimized for apple
silicon you guys see the difference
5.9 seconds under six compared to 33 and
a half for blender guys this is crazy
and the fans were pretty much off
compared to just blaring and taking a
while to cool down now i'm also going to
run the splashbox test a lot more people
test this and this one is actually only
using the cpu it's not using the gpu we
have a lot less differences with the
cpus between these two machines but
let's go ahead and hit run alright guys
this time we have a smaller difference
but it's still there we have 20 seconds
for the m1 max with its eight
performance cores and two efficiency
cores that don't do much compared to 31
seconds for the eight core i9 the best
intel processor in any
macbook pro those results line up with
cinebench basically 50 faster cpu
performance for rendering and once again
for blender and other 3d rendering
programs this is a pretty massive jump
next we are testing affinity photo you
guys asked for it i went out and i
bought it we're running their built-in
benchmark which makes it nice and easy
to see a wide range of performance with
affinity so let's go ahead and get
started and then we'll jump into
photoshop in lightroom as well
these benchmarks are just not stopping
at all so
we're going to keep going give you guys
all the results all right guys the
scores are in and this is pretty crazy
i'll zoom in and let you guys see both
of them here i'm just gonna comment on
the combined scores but you guys could
see all the singles for yourself as far
as the multi-cpu we get 37 faster
performance with the m1 max the 10 core
and the pro would be the same but for
the graphics we have 4.6 times faster
performance
with that graphics compared to the 5600m
that's a crazy difference because like
in metal like in geekbench you guys saw
the difference wasn't anywhere near that
not even double so if you're using
affinity with all their awesome
optimized graphics acceleration the
results are well you guys see for
yourselves we keep just having crazy
differences next we are jumping into
photoshop i have a few different tests
for you guys to see the performance
difference the first thing is going to
be an hdr test i have nine 42 megapixel
raw images let's go ahead and hit merge
to hdr we're gonna see how long this
takes the cpus are maxed out man this is
a slow process i don't know how you guys
do it you have to switch to affinity
because the cpus are not even being hit
hard they maxed out and they stopped wow
okay so it looks like the intel was
first there we still have to have it
create the final file
and then here looks like it's still
merging it and creating a better quality
bam that finally finished on the intel
we're still going on the m1 max chip but
it's weird because the cpu is only
sitting at 21
and when we tested the 14 inch in
lightroom it was way faster than intel's
but i guess we'll wait bam okay now it
finally got finished that was very weird
but the nine took two minutes and 24
seconds compared to three minutes and 48
seconds we'll have to try that again in
lightroom maybe camera raw isn't running
properly i'm not sure the next thing i'm
going to test is super resolution i'm
going to go ahead and hit this enhance
button
and we'll run enhance right here as well
that took 32 seconds with the m1 max and
38 with the i9 once again
very close results there that one one
but not by as much as in lightroom so
there we go let's go ahead and just
close this now let's jump into lightroom
and see maybe it's more optimized for
apple silicon than photoshop i'm going
to hit hdr with the same exact files
the preview is already being made here
bam now it's creating the final hdr file
these things are actually really close
for this bam the m1 is done let's wait
for the intel and bam right there the
intel machine is done
that took three minutes and 19 seconds
compared to two minutes and four seconds
so about a third faster for the m1 max
and the same thing goes for the m1 pro
because it's mostly cpu-based tasks when
you're doing this hdr and now let's go
ahead and enhance both of these i'm
gonna hit this button to get started
right away all right both of them are
done this thing just finished it's beach
balling i already hit the timer
we have a minute and 30 seconds for the
eight core i9 macbook and we have 47
seconds for our m1 max apple silicon 16
inch that means that the new macbook is
almost twice as fast if you're doing
this in adobe lightroom classic so if
you're doing these tests do it here it
does look like it's optimized for apple
silicon and maybe photoshop or at least
adobe camera raw isn't yet and now we're
gonna launch 50 high resolution edited
files here as far as the program even
the core i9 was the best of the best
super smooth no issues but what happens
when we go to export these now before we
run this export i have to show you guys
the battery life because we need to plug
this machine in we just got a low power
rating and it is that three percent
battery life remaining we've been doing
this for a couple hours running these
and a couple hours is all last with such
high cpu and gpu wattage now take a
guess
what our m1 max 16 inch is at you guys
can comment down below
let's go ahead and take a look and bam
49
basically 50 showing us that literally
it sucks half the power even has a much
higher resolution display that's mini
led
compared to the intel version so you can
get four hours of pushing this machine
to its limits and it'll still perform
great even though its graphics does use
a lot more power than the m1 pro chip
bam we are done with the 16 inch m1 max
chip and with the i9
look at that we are not even at 50
almost right there so let's go ahead and
wait and bam we are done
with the i9
that took three minutes and five seconds
with that machine still really fast that
was really good results it was worth
spending 4100 on this laptop but now for
3
500 600 less it did it in a minute and
21 seconds guys that is
2.3 times faster so yeah more than twice
as fast that really shows the advantage
of unified memory when you have a
program that is optimized because our
cpu performance was only 50 faster and
that's mostly what it's using right now
but obviously it did this in you know
twice as fast so that just shows you
what the m1 chip can do with all those
optimizations all right guys let's go
ahead and close lightroom classic and
now finally let's get into video editing
we're going to use final cut pro and
then switch over to davinci resolve the
first test i have is going to be
interesting this is something brand new
this is using final cut's new tracker
i'm going to grab my color board for
grading i'm gonna select noaa right here
i'll do it on the m1 system as well and
then we're gonna hit analyze at the same
time
bam oh my goodness is that even going
look at that on the m1 bam it is done
and the intel it only got started once
the m1 was completely done the m1 max
bam it is complete all right guys so
that was an 18 second clip it took 31
seconds with the i9 5600m basically
twice as long the m1 max took six
seconds to analyze that clip it is using
that machine learning that is incredible
now we all know that prores and prayers
raw edits really nicely in final cut you
guys can see right here neither systems
have any issues but what i'm going to do
is to go over to
ak so basically this is an ak timeline
that has stacks of this footage because
i don't actually have a key footage but
this is the same thing both actually
play back surprisingly well it's a lot
easier for the m1 max model to do it and
what we're gonna do is we are going to
export this one minute project it's not
five minutes like before bam we are
exporting and we'll see how these do
geez right away the m1 max is at 38 now
40 compared to seven
so it is just flying through this export
and i think this is actually faster than
my fifteen thousand dollar mac pro
that has that afterburner card when i
was testing it that is crazy all right
wow i was not expecting
that big of a difference
we have three minutes and 55 seconds for
a one minute timeline to export this 8k
pro res raw compared to
37
seconds that is six and a half times
faster basically if you had a 10 minute
project it would take pretty much 40
minutes on this one compared to
six minutes or so on this machine that
is incredible and now we are in davinci
resolve we are going to start out by
testing stabilization which uses all the
graphics horsepower this is a one minute
4k clip to stabilize let's hit that and
hit our timer right away the m1 max is
flying the 5600 m took 46 seconds
compared to 28 so definitely a big
improvement next i'm gonna export a five
minute hevc timeline that is color
graded and we didn't do a simple project
that most people do in final cut so i'm
gonna do it here let's hit render and
see how they do look at that the m1 max
is exporting at 92 frames per second
compared to 45 now neither of these
machines graphics are being maxed out
we're not limited by the cpu or the gpu
or the ram just the encoders and of
course the m1 max has new encoders that
are way faster all right guys we have a
result and the 5600m with i9 took two
minutes and 39 seconds compared to one
minute and 19 seconds literally twice as
fast with the new machine
so you're just flying through exports
with this thing now i promised you guys
some black magic raw here is some 6k
black ragic raw from the pocket 6k
looks like both of them are playing it
back really easily
no issues whatsoever they're both very
high-end machines and this codec is nice
and efficient this is one area where the
m1 chip does suffer once you add
multiple luts that i have right here but
with the m1 max no issues and i suspect
the m1 pro also plays back perfectly
fine now let's go ahead and export this
in this case i'm going out to prores 422
and let's take a look at that wow 100
frames per second for this 6k exporting
compared to 49 here oh no the i9 slowed
down to 32 or 30 frames per second now
because of thermal throttling the fans
are going full blast 29 now bam the m1
max is done and this thing is still
going now at 26
frames per second
that's crazy it started out at 49. wow
all right bm we are finally done
that is a much bigger difference than i
expected that took over four minutes
four minutes and five seconds for the
intel system compared to one minute and
13 seconds this thing was completely
silent once again
that is over three times faster
almost four times faster
that's incredible that's like
what a 20 minute video that's black
magic raw literally exporting in under
five minutes
that is insane uh compared to a 20
minute video taking
i don't know what is that let me do the
math i'm terrible at doing the math an
hour and a half or something like that i
don't know that's crazy you guys tell me
down below alright guys hopefully you
enjoyed me putting these machines
through torture testing and benchmarking
real life scenarios let me know do you
think it's worth buying and upgrading to
an m1 max for 600 cheaper than the
highest end configuration last year um i
think so not only is the performance way
better it runs way quieter and cooler
and with that it also saves you 600
bucks so the battery life is absolutely
crazy you guys saw that it was basically
a 50 when this one died at this point
we're still at 18
after a bunch more tests and downloads
and setting up between shooting it is
just absolutely crazy now if you guys
want to win a 2500
m1 pro macbook make sure you guys are
subscribed you guys comment below on
this video and check out the other
videos that we already posted and
they're coming out later this week like
that comparison to the razer one uh or
our ram comparison between 16 and 32
gigs or 32 and 64. that gives you more
chances the more you comment between
four different videos it helps your
chances so go and check that out make
sure you guys are subscribed of course i
am just way too tired after shooting so
many of these videos but we have more
exciting ones to come and if you made it
this far if you haven't yet checked out
our merch we have a bunch of cool shirts
like this limited scribble shirt uh this
is going away after this week you can
use the code m1 pro to save 20 off the
links are down in the video description
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and i will see you in the next
video
[Music]